هل يمكن القول بشكل قاطع ان العقوبات على
روسيا فشلت
كلا لا نستطيع ان نقول ذلك العقوبات
فشلت
في ايصال النتائج التي تحدث عنها الكثير
من السياسيين او التي يرغبون فيها اذا ما
سمعنا الى خطابهم قبل عام كان ذلك حديث
كثير عن العقوبات والتي ستنجم عن ازمات
مباشره وفوريه داخل روسيا وانهيار
الاقتصادي ولمعايير المعيشه وبالتالي
ستقود الى انتفاضه شعبيه وتغيير في
القياده وارقام روسيا الخروج من اوكرانيا
في ذلك
فشلت العقوبات تماما وتجد اي ادله على
حصول اي من ذلك الى الان ولا يوجد حتى
مخاطر من حصول ذلك ولكن من الجانب الاخر
اصبح لديها اثر بطيء فلم تكن او تحصل
هنالك ازمه حقيقيه ولا حتى احتمال وجود
ازمه عميقه في روسيا ولكن روسيا الان
تواجه
انحدارا بطيئا بسبب تراكم العقوبات ولانها
يستطيع ان تجلب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه
لانها لا تستطيع الوصول الى التكنولوجيا
الغربيه وبالتالي فسيكون هنالك انحدار
بطيء في الاقتصاد الروسي وبالتالي سيؤثر
على اسلوب معيشه الاشخاص وجوده الحياه
وانواع الخدمات المتاحه للصناعه الروسيه
والشعب الروسي كل هذه سوف تزداد سوء من
خلال سنوات المقبله
واحده او في جانب واحد ونتساءل عن تاثير
هذه العقوبات على مستقبل الحرب
[موسيقى]
نعم ولكن مره اخرى من ملاحظاتي الشخصيه
هنا في موسكو والتحدث مع الاشخاص
اليهم اقول بان المزاج في روسيا ايضا الان
مختلف عن ما كان عليه في العمل الماضي في
العمل الماضي كانوا اكثر خوفا وتشككا وحتى
غاضبين احيانا ما حصل
ومتخوفين ما سيحصل اما الان استطيع ان
اقول بين المزاج اصبح فيه تحدي اكبر
الاحساس القومي ويرون بلا شك ان هذا
النزاع الان على انه حرب بين روسيا وبين
الناتو وبين روسيا والغرب
فقد انتقل بعيدا عن مجرد حرب اوكرانيا
فبات الشعب يرى ان اوكرانيا تحارب من اجل
بقائها وهكذا تغير المزاج والان هم
مستعدون لتحمل المزيد من الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وبصراحه الى الان
لم يواجه الكثير منها ولكن ان حصلت فسوف
يتحملونها لانهم يشعرون بان بلادهم مهدده
وبالتالي فهذا شيء عليهم ان يتحملهم من
اجل بقاء بلادهم فالمزاج الان مختلف تماما
ولهم كثيره من العزيمه والاصرار والعناد
والكثير من القوميه فاخشى ان لم يكن هنالك
اي انجاز سياسي فلا ارى ان الحكومه
الروسيه سترغم لا اقتصاديا او بسبب
العقوبات او حتى بسبب الراي العام المحلي
لا ارى انها سترغم على عكس قرارها والخروج
من اوكرانيا تحت اي ظروف المعقوله لفتره
طويله جدا واذا ما انتهت الحرب
اتفاق سياسي مع الغرب ولن يكون بسبب
العقوبات الاقتصاديه او الضغوط المحليه في
روسيا